[Music]
welcome back to another episode of
what's up prof
hello walter hello martin
are we kicking off some
interesting things again today
well there are so many
problems
surrounding this subject and so many
misunderstandings
and
you know sometimes one has to do a thing
three four five six seven times and then
we still don't understand it
yes let's see where we can get with this
one okay so i'll open with a word of
prayer
our heavenly father we are here once
again and we ask let you please help us
enlighten our minds with the holy spirit
and bless the discussion in jesus name
amen amen
now modern again we're talking about
bibles
and it's a very sensitive subject with
very
emotional attachments and some people
are
so adamant about one side or the other
side that this will lead to a holy war
true
and
it shows you how important it is
that you were even banned
in a country because of it yes speech
speaking and yeah you see and it's also
necessary that we again look at this and
hopefully we can do a thorough one
and explain it to people because
sometimes even what we say
don't seem to come through like we mean
it
sometimes people misunderstand
what is being said
and
that is a problem so if titled that the
truth will set you free
and john 8
32 is the verse that comes to mind then
and you shall know the truth
and the truth shall make you free that's
a very important aspect right
you have to know the truth and once you
know the truth the truth will make you
free
if you want to accept and internalize
this very important
statement here in this verse isn't it
imperative that you know what truth is
exactly you must know what truth is yeah
because only the truth can make you free
so if you don't know the truth you're in
bondage
perfect
because
it's the same like you said
if you tell people to come out of
babylon but you don't define babylon it
doesn't have any meaning no so if you
don't know what the truth is or you
think you know what it is then you're in
trouble if you don't if you're not in
the truth but you think you're in the
truth so we must know what truth is
now do you think that the devil is the
enemy of truth yes
he's a liar from the beginning right
he's the father of lies
so definitely he doesn't like truth
so we've defined truth in this
whole series i mean so many times it's
unbelievable
but let's go in a little bit more detail
just to see
where we stand
and you know martin this issue of truth
causes
consternation
and conflict
at every level
it causes conflict with the secular
world
it causes conflict with the religious
and it causes conflict even within the
same denominations including our
own so it must be a very big issue
definitely and also you mentioned now
that the satan
is
opposed to truth he hates truth with a
passion but then all his agents will
also have to be opposed to it
absolutely
all right
so
let's have a look what the papacy says
about truth according to the scripture
it's very important that you know the
truth because otherwise you're in
bondage right
so pope francis says and this is again
from the jesuit review
it seems like that is one of our
favorite journals
[Laughter]
not in a positive sense
no pope francis those who insist on
keeping the truth over preaching the
gospel have always threatened the church
that's a very strange statement to make
right
now tell me martin is there a difference
between the gospel and the truth
and they can't be and
you know that's so um ridiculous
it's a saying
that
this pot is here but it's not containing
the flowers all right
now if you say the gospel the word
gospel means good news right yeah
now the good news is that you're no
longer going to be in bondage but you're
going to be set free
what was the thing that was going to set
you free the truth all right so keeping
the truth
is not important
this is amazing i don't even want to
read at all
but you know they have these little
statements like keepers of the truth
they call themselves
now
are there keepers of the lie
yes
i wonder who's the keeper of the lie on
this planet now if they talk derogatory
about the keeper of the truth
satan's job was to keep
the com the truth to protect the
commandments he was a covering cherub
yes so that sounds
similar to what he would be saying about
derogatory
talking over people keeping the truth
all right
then he talks about these christians
that claim that they're keeping the
truth and they strongly affirm that the
true christianity is the one they adhere
to
often identified with certain forms of
the past
and that the solution to the crisis of
today is to go back so as not to lose
the genuineness of the faith
he's obviously talking about the
reformation in couch terms
because they're quoting the pope right
so he's saying let's not go back to
reformation times when these people say
thy word is truth
and we must stick to the truth so
therefore we must stick to the bible no
no no we've come we've we've passed that
now
we're now with
our variant of the truth which happens
to be a lie
and that's true okay
so one of the traces of this way of
proceeding is inflexibility
now martin how flexible can you be
when it comes to jesus christ is the
only way to salvation
there's no way you can be any flexible
must you become inflexible
how do you
how do you deal with the other
major religions on the planet that deny
that jesus is the only
way that we can come to the father you
have to get rid of him so you have to
become flexible
so you must sacrifice truth
for fraternity that's it is that right
okay
so this
inflexibility as he calls it is a bane
is a enemy in his eyes yeah so that you
have to become so flexible that this
brotherly love this love your neighbor
can
go over
jesus christ so you must become a rubber
man
now you know in the old days they called
the rubber man spineless
faced with the preaching of the gospel
that makes us free ah but martin
the preaching of the gospel makes us
free now the question is
which gospel makes us free
the true gospel
okay now what did jesus say makes us
free the truth
so once again we're back at that we're
in trouble we're in trouble here right
okay that makes us joyful what makes us
joyful that you're free from what from
the bondage of truth
that's what he's saying yeah that's
exactly okay these people are rigid
always the rigidity you must do this you
must do that inflexibility is typical of
these people
now martin when it comes to the position
of christ
as the mediator of the covenant
as the savior of the world
as the righteousness
of the saints
is there
any leeway for flexibility no not at all
and even if you
go to the other part of truth which is
the law
can you have a flexibility on
thou shalt not steal
well according to thomas aquinas yes yes
and he's a saint according to them so
then you can see by their fruits
where they where it leads you all right
so the new preachers do not know what
humility is
and here's that famous word of his
fraternity
now that document that he wrote about
fraternity was signed by other major
religion in the world that denies that
jesus is the only way right that's it
that's flexibility
but is it truth
not at all not according to the bible
definition okay
so this flexibility in this fraternity
it is the path of meek and obedient
trust the new preachers know neither
meekness nor obedience
obedience to whom that's the question
because who defines that obedience and
meekness not the bible obviously he does
right he's very cheerful over there and
he has
great plans for fraternity
at the cost of truth
so this is a very serious issue to come
up with something like that i'm afraid
you have to be a jesuit
let me go to our own church
this is a
statement
that was made by the general conference
president robert pearson when he
addressed the general conference
for the last time in his capacity as the
president of the general conference in
1978.
just to show that some of these issues
can even find their way into our own
ranks
i'm not going to read the whole document
because it's rather lengthy we can put a
link in
so we'll summarize some of it and read
some of it
an earnest appeal from the retiring
president of the general conference
presented to annual council on october
15 1978.
quote this will be the last time that in
my present role i shall stand before the
world leaders of my church your church
our church
and i have a few words to leave with you
elder pearson then proceeds to describe
how a church can become complacent and
lose its compass
once it had passed from the sectarian
image
to a fully accepted church status with
worldly accreditation
so worldly accreditation becomes a
problem right
yes to be
accepted by the world yes
and then he states brethren and sisters
this must never happen to the
seventh-day adventist church this will
not happen to the seventh-day adventist
church this is
not just another church it is
god's church
so it's a in a it's an appeal
shouldn't happen
why did he do this because it was
already happening right
he said already brethren and sisters
there are subtle forces that are
beginning to stir regrettably
there are those in the church who
belittle the inspiration of the bible
martin is that fighting against truth
yes
okay
where are these people regrettably there
are those
in the church
who belittle the inspiration of the
bible
who scorned the first 11 chapters of
genesis
who questioned the spirit of prophecy's
short chronology of the earth now what
and we've dealt with that many times and
we seem to be
facing this war over and over because
already then they were fighting against
the short chronology they seem to have
perfected it right now and seem to be at
war with anybody who adheres to it
all right so the short chronology of the
earth
and who subtly and not so subtly attack
the spirit of prophecy
there are some who point to the
reformers and contemporary theologians
as a source and the norm for seventh-day
adventist doctrine
so some of them love the higher critics
and seem to run along with them and
embrace what they have to say
there are those who allegedly are tired
of the hackneyed phrases of adventism
they are those who wish to forget the
standard
of the church we love
that includes things like health reform
dress reform etc
there are those who covet and would
caught the favor of the evangelicals
evangelical movements echomenism all of
these things
those who would throw off the mantle of
a peculiar people and those who would go
the way of the secular materialistic
world
fellow leaders beloved brethren and
sisters don't let it happen
i appeal to you as earnestly as i know
how this morning don't let it happen
martin is it happening it has happened
and it's still happening okay
are we often in the middle of this
war i appealed to andrews university to
the seminary to loma linda university
don't let it happen
we are not seventh day
anglicans not seventh day lutherans we
are seventh day adventists this is god's
last church with god's last message
so this war is raging
and
people will have to decide one way or
the other
and truth is involved
inspiration of the bible is involved
short chronology is involved spirit of
prophecy is involved any one of these
issues economism is involved
accreditation is involved
all of these issues
yes and if you get trapped into any of
them can you be torn away from truth
that's exactly what happens
he continued you are the men and women
the leaders whom god is counting on to
keep the seventh-day adventist church
god's remnant church
the church god is destined to triumph
the servant of the lord says fearful
perils are before those who bear
responsibility in the lord's work
perils the thought of which make me
tremble
and in ezekiel 22 30 we read i looked
for a man amongst them who could build a
barricade who could stand before me in
the bridge to defend the land from ruin
i believe this morning fellow leaders
that god is looking for men and women
intrepid leaders men and women who love
god's church and god's truth
more than they love their lives
to see that this church under god goes
through to the kingdom the task ahead of
us is not going to be easy
if i understand the bible and the spirit
of prophecy are right this morning ahead
lies a time of trouble a time of
challenge such as this church and this
world have never
before known
we've
entered the precursors to this time
and anybody that wants to say the
contrary
i don't know on which planet you're
living
well martin
let's go back to this definition on the
bible of truth
which we have discussed so many times
already
and let's just look at it in the light
of what we are discussing now
john chapter 14 verse 6
jesus said unto him i am the way the
truth and the life no man comes unto the
father but by me
this single statement
is the most controversial statement
in the bible
it is by itself responsible
for the destruction and war
between factions on this earth such as
we will never understand until the books
of record are opened
how many
millions and millions have lost their
lives because of that single statement
probably most wars link back to this
so maybe
some people will say oh why god did you
put it in there
because if it's not in there you no
longer have the truth exactly right i
just wanted to say because all truth
hangs on this verse okay
he's the truth i'm the way the truth and
the life no man comes unto the father
but by me
okay
does islam embrace this verse
does buddhism embrace it
does hinduism embrace it does shamanism
embrace it does zoroasterism embrace it
does the new age movement embrace it
does catholicism embrace it no they
believe in fraternity
so who embraces it
only the people that keep the truth the
fanatics the rigid ones
that have
no that that should become spineless
right
according to
the gentleman in the vatican
all right so jesus is the way and the
truth
the second definition is sanctify them
through thy truth thy word is truth it's
interesting that jesus is also the word
so you cannot divorce the word from
jesus so if you take away jesus then
you've got no truth because you don't
have a word you know
whose word do you have then anybody's
right could you then change it yes
that's how they do it
isn't that interesting so if you take
away the first one then you can change
the word but that's the same with the
commandment if you take the authority
who is jesus in the fourth commandment
away then you can do what you want with
the rest of the commandments all right
so anybody who tampers with the word is
tampering with the truth and therefore
is tampering with jesus
because it's also called the testimony
of jesus that's it which is the spirit
of prophecy so where does that come from
jesus again okay so we're in trouble
over here martin i i hope that you
realize that in this in this war
the spineless fraternity attitude at all
costs
is a problem rigidity is absolutely
necessary for salvation
i don't think the vatican will like that
statement no
they say that that's the problem with
the world and has been yes
and then the next one is psalms 119 thy
righteousness is an everlasting
righteousness and thy law is the truth
of verse 151 they are near our lord and
all thy commandments are truth
so those are the definitions of truth
jesus is the truth the word is the truth
the law is the truth the commandments to
be
quite specific
so let's have a look at the first one
we are in trouble no matter what we say
we're going to get it from all sides
even from within
that's well the bible also says that it
will happen and the spirit of prophecy
makes it clear so we'll have to if you
want to uphold truth you have to expect
to get
the stone that was rejected became
the capstone
do not think that i've come to bring
peace
but there will be division right
okay
john 1 verse 1
in the beginning was the word and the
word was with god and the word
was god
it's a brilliant way of putting it
because you've encapsulated
christ as the word
and you have declared them to be god
exactly and from everlasting
in the beginning was god it was the word
now when the jehovah's witness bible
came out and they changed this verse
on the basis of westcott and hort and
some jesuit scholars
to
a god with a
lowercase g
there was a big furor
and they only made a couple of changes
if they were to look at the scriptures
today
and the changes that have been made in
modern translations
i think
those old pioneers would be spinning in
their graves
but you know time
has its way
of
covering up that which was very plain
ones to become very obscure today that's
true
all right what about john 14 verse 6
jesus said unto him them i am the way
the truth and the life no man cometh
unto the father but by me let's just
read that again because this is a key
verse
and here's a statement from letters and
manuscripts christ is god
as well as man
that's pretty straightforward
he who was with the father before the
world was became flesh and dwelt amongst
us we may behold his glory
and the glory is his character
those who receive the son of god become
sons of god
they are his spiritual children born
again renewed in righteousness and true
holiness their minds are changed
with clearer vision they behold eternal
realities they are adopted into god's
family and they become conformed into
his likeness
changed by his spirit from glory to
glory
from cherishing supreme love for self
they come to cherish supreme love for
god and for christ
okay
so the opening statement christ is god
as well
as
man what would the quran do with that
i'm going to throw it away we have a
serious problem with it right
here's another
quote from manuscripts 101 he was equal
with god infinite and omnipotent
he is
the eternal
self-existent
son a very important statement
so he's from all eternity
and he's self-existent
he wasn't created
he cannot be he wasn't generated
he is the eternal
self-existent son a very
complex
idea
to grapple with
another statement from the review and
herald april 5 1906 from everlasting
while god's word speaks of the humanity
of christ when upon this earth it also
speaks decidedly regarding his
pre-existence
the word existed as a divine being even
as the eternal son of god in union and
oneness with his father
from everlasting he was the mediator of
the covenant the one in whom all nations
of the earth both jews and gentiles if
they accepted him
it's conditional
a way to be blessed
the word was with god
and the word was god before men or
angels were created the word was with
god and was god
that's just echoing
what
john said in his opening statement
all right let's just pick it up in the
book of
hebrews chapter 1
god
who at sundry times and in diverse
manners spoke in times past unto the
fathers by the prophets has in these
last days spoken unto us by his son
whom he had the pointed heir of all
things by whom also he made the worlds
who being the brightness of his glory
and the express image of his person
upholding all things by the word of his
power
when he had by himself
purged our sins sat down on the right
hand of the majesty on high
that's also a beautiful statement in
scripture
and if we discuss this statement there's
a discussion of this very statement in
the review in herald 1907
and it says here the position of jesus
christ in reference to his father is
brought to view
while they are one in purpose
one in mind yet in personality
they are
two
may we not learn from this that there is
to be a unity between believers
it's an interesting point right
so if there's unity between the father
and the son then there should be a
possibility of union between us
if our thinking is based on truth
correct
even though we have different
personalities yes
may we not learn from this
that there is to be unity between
believers there's no reason why one
should feel that it is necessary for him
to bring others to the exact line of his
own individuality
so long as we are subject to the
temptations of satan we shall each have
all we can possibly attend to in order
to maintain a right relation to god
that christ may do for us his atoning
work
and though we may differ in the form of
words and in the expression of our
individuality
yes our words may be sanctified and our
characters purified through the
sacrifice of christ
so we need to be of one mind
how do you come
to be in one mind you have to have the
same basis the same anchor ah you must
you must stand on the same foundation
so your personality is different
because we're individuals
and nobody ever asks you and god does
not require of you to give up your
personality
but your
knowledge of what truth is must be based
on a very solid foundation
okay
now let's bring the holy spirit into
this the comforter that christ promised
to send after the ascended to heaven is
the spirit in all the fullness of the
godhead
making manifest the power of divine
grace to all who receive and believe in
christ
as a personal savior
there are three living persons
of the heavenly trio
in the name of these three great powers
the father the son the holy spirit
those who receive christ by living faith
are baptized
and these powers will co-operate with
the obedient subjects of heaven
in their efforts to live the new life in
christ
now martin anyone who wants to argue the
point
has to argue not only with scripture
which says baptize them in the name of
the father the son and the holy spirit
or they would have to argue with this
statement but please
don't argue with you or with me on the
issue this is what it says that's it and
that's what the scriptures say
i can maybe just mention there is some
dispute about these statements yes and
them being not from the sp alan white
herself
but i'll we'll attach a document that's
the
ellen white estate made
and there is
own handwriting and there's quite a few
statements that has exactly this yes so
we cannot dispute that it
is in her original handwriting
and by the way it's what the scripture
says
that's what the scripture says
the pre-existent self-existent son of
god
the article in the psalms of times
christ is the pre-existent
self-existent son of god
in speaking of his pre-existence christ
carries the mind back through dateless
ages
he assures us that there never was a
time when he was not in close fellowship
with the eternal god he whose voice the
jews were then listening had been with
god as one brought up with him
he was equal with god infinite and
omnipotent he is the eternal
self-existent son
so there was never a time when he was
not
and it's
sad that you want to
downgrade jesus
if you if there's an effort to downgrade
jesus
then the whole plan of salvation falls
apart
so let's just make this quite clear
because this is a very controversial
issue let's take a look at the catholic
view of christ
catholicism claims that christ is
generated
and here is the web page www
and these are the points the father
actively and eternally generates the sun
that contradicts what we've just read
exactly because it's self-existent and
everlasting and have been from
everlasting
all right so they claim that the father
actively and eternally generates the son
constituting the person of god the
father so the father was there he
generated the son
this is catholic catholic thinking
the son is passively generated of the
father which constitutes the person of
the son
so
they are making christ
in a sense
a generated being
point number three the father and the
son actively spirit
the holy spirit in the one relation
within the inner life of god that does
not constitute a person
it does not do so because the father and
the son are already constituted as
persons in relation to each other in the
first two relations this is why the
catholic catechism 240 teachers
the second person of the blessed trinity
is the son only in relation to his
father
so the holy spirit according to
catholicism was spirated that comes from
the word breath
so in other words jesus breathed the
father breathed and this spirated the
holy spirit
so in the sense the holy spirit also is
not a separate person or entity
it is a consequence of spiration
fourth point the holy spirit is
passively spirated of the father and the
son constituting the person of the holy
spirit
so in actual fact the only true god is
the father
who generates the son
who together spirit the holy spirit that
is catholic
that's catholic trinity doctrine yes
all right they continue
we should take note of the distinction
between the generative procession that
constitutes the sun
and the spirated procession that
constitutes the holy spirit
as
i find it so hard to say this but
it says then the document sent thomas
aquinas
so let's read it as it says even if it
is hard to read it that way
as saint thomas aquinas explains
and scripture reveals the son is
uniquely begotten of the father they
quote john
he is also said to proceed from the
father as the word
in john 1 verse 1.
but in one verse one it doesn't say that
it doesn't say that it says he was with
god yes
when it says i came from the father the
word that the bible uses is para
from which we get the word parallel
means from the side of not in the sense
of coming out of yes not like eve was
from made from the rib it's not the same
word
so this generative procession is one of
begetting but not in the same way a dog
begets a dog or a human
being begets a human being this is an
intellectual begetting and fittingly so
as a word proceeds from the knower while
at the same time remaining in the knower
now
this deprives christ of being the actual
word he is in this only the word in as
far as he proceeds out of the father
so it actually denies the individuality
the absolute
individuality of christ as the son
thus this procession of or begetting of
the son occurs within the inner life of
god
there are not two beings involved
rather two persons rationally distinct
while ever remaining one in being
now what you have there is a
multi-headed god
the holy spirit proceeds from the father
and the son but not in a generative
sense rather in a spiration
spiration comes from the latin word for
spirit or breath jesus breathed on them
and said received the holy spirit john
20 22. so this is catholic doctrine
and
many in the protestant world have
internalized this rather than what the
scriptures say support it also
by what the spirit of prophecy has to
say yes
so modern catholicism believes
that jesus was generated
so let's just look at a verse where this
becomes a very interesting point
if you go to matthew 1 verse 18
gnostic writers have changed just one
letter in the greek
to make christ a created being
whose origin started at his birth this
perversion is found only in the
following manuscripts p1
the synepticus
the vaticanus
six majuscals and a few miniscules
almost all the modern translations don't
dare to include this perversion but
follow the received text the tr
rather than their preferred most ancient
manuscripts as they like to call them
but of course the jesuit inspired you a
bible shows no such sensibilities let's
show it you see that's for me a very
interesting
occurrence
so they the new translations they keep
on telling you we have to go with those
manuscripts but on this issue they'll
use the received text yes because they
know that they will get into trouble
with the
christian world so yes so they're not
very true to their own conviction
absolutely correct
so let's look at it martin
matthew 1 verse 18
king james version
received text right
now the birth of jesus christ and the
greek there is gnessus
was in this wise when his mother mary
had was espoused to joseph before they
came together
she was found with child of the holy
ghost now
matthew 1 verse 18 in the jewish version
just changes one letter
now the generation
can you see it catholic doctrine
of christ
greek for that would be
genesis
so they leave out one n
and it changes the entire meaning
was in this wise
when as his mother mary was espoused to
joseph before they came together she was
found with child of the holy ghost
martin they've changed one letter
and have changed the entire
existence of jesus christ and removed
his pre-existence
that's a sad state of affairs isn't that
a sad state of affairs contrary
to the great cloud of witnesses out
there
that even
the translators of the modern bibles
don't dare include this
let's have a look at another one the
equality of the son with the father 1
timothy 3 16 nestle alant
renders god was manifest in the flesh as
he was manifest in the flesh so you'll
find the modern translations which
follow the nestle alant
directives
will change this verse to he was
manifest
so this rendition is based on five major
schools
among which
the syneticus is the prime
exhibit
and a few minuscules thus excluding the
great cloud of witnesses to the country
so this opens the way for jesus to be
just a created being as gnosses would
have it and as official catholic
doctrine implies
so the niv follows the n a by
translating it he was manifest
and in 1 timothy 6 14 and 15 there's
another very interesting change let's
just read it in the king james version
first
that thou keep this commandment without
spot
unrebukable until the appearing of our
lord jesus christ
which in his times he shall show who is
the blessed and only potentate the king
of kings and lord of lords
this is the king james version now read
it very carefully shall we read it again
martin
that thou keep this commandment without
spot unrebukable until the appearing of
our lord jesus christ so
in context
who is the verse talking about jesus
christ okay
which in his times he shall show who is
the blessed and only potentate the king
of kings
who's it talking about jesus christ and
lord of lords who's it talking about
still all right so in the context this
verse deals with jesus christ
with the son
let's read it in the niv
to keep this command without spot or
blame until the appearing of our lord
jesus christ
same
to this point
but now
which god will bring about in his own
time daesh god the blessed and only
ruler king of kings and lord of lords
all right so in their context it is
possible that these verses can now refer
to the father
but the title king of kings uniquely
belongs to christ in the new testament
and so it is rendered in the king james
however the niv
adds the word god twice
in verse 15
although it does not appear in the
original so that jesus is deprived of
his place and title in these verses
so this is a serious issue this is
exactly where the doctrine then comes
from that he's a created being so is
this is this an attempt to sneak in
catholic doctrine yes would you say so i
would think so
i would think so
all right let's leave the discussion
there
when it comes to to jesus
obviously
according to the bible
jesus was there from the beginning it's
a very difficult concept to understand
yeah but that is what the scripture says
and he is equal with the father para
from the side of the father
eternally
one in mind with the father but two
beings
and the holy spirit is part of that
heavenly trio
that's what the bible touched their
purpose and they've all got their and
jesus if you want to make him any less
than you've with the bible is telling us
then he couldn't have come to save
our us from sin
martin let's look at the second aspect
of truth the word is truth
now when we talk about the word we speak
about the whole bible right
so this could be quite a lengthy process
so let's try and make us as painless as
possible
when god's word is studied comprehended
and obeyed a bright light will be
reflected to the world new truths
received and acted upon will bind us in
strong bonds to jesus
what binds us to jesus
the truth
truth where do i discover it in the
bible in the word and when i believe it
i'm showing that i believe god
and not the serpent
didn't the serpent say did god really
say exactly and then twist his words yep
yeah
so is it possible that that same certain
will say did god really say
and then change the manuscript to say
something else yes is it possible it is
possible and then all that follow on
there will do this exact same all the
translations
the bible and the bible alone is to be
our creed the soul bond of union
all who bow to this holy word will be in
harmony
martin is it important that we have the
right holy word if we want to be in
harmony yes
okay if we want to be in harmony in
truth
our own views and ideas must not control
our efforts
man is fallible
but god's word is infallible
instead of wrangling with one another
let men exalt the lord let us meet all
opposition as did our master saying it
is written
let us lift up the banner on which is
inscribed the bible our rule of faith
and discipline
it's very important
that i know
what the bible says
and it's very important that i have a
bible that says what god said correct
now let's just see if it's possible to
confuse this issue and we've dealt with
this many times but let's put it there
again for clarity
the valdor churches that's the valdenzas
in their purity and simplicity resembled
the church of the apostolic times
rejecting the supremacy of pope and
prelate they held the bible as the only
supreme infallible authority
their pastors unlike the lordly priests
of rome followed the example of their
master who came not to be ministered to
unto but to minister
they fed the flock of god leading them
to green pastures and living fountains
of his holy word
far from the monuments of human pomp and
pride
the people assembled not in magnificent
churches or grand cathedrals but beneath
the shadow of the mountains of the
alpine valleys
or in times of danger in some rocky
stronghold to listen to the words of
truth from the servants of christ
pastors not only preached the gospel but
they visited the sick catechized the
children admonished the urine
labored to settle disputes and promote
harmony and brotherly love
in times of peace they were sustained by
the free will offerings of the people
but like paul the tent maker
each learned some trade or profession by
which if necessary
to provide for his own support
now according to the spirit of prophecy
they were the true custodians of the
real true word of god
that's it and not
the proud hierarchy
in rome so there were two
sets of manuscripts
now the modern bible versions differ
from the received text
which
the valdenzus had
and which the church in the east had
which the byzantine church had
and which the reformers
gave to the world
see so it comes from before the
reformation yes
so
this saying that the received text
is only from the 1520s
and let's make quite plain the original
manuscripts which are called the
autographs
no longer exist
they don't exist all we have is copies
and
they were copied from originals
and they were sent
to the various churches so there were
many copies of the original autographs
now martin
if i have a recipe let me explain this
again if i have a recipe
and i sent it to
my friend
this is how you do this this is the
original recipe
and then
that one says oh this is a wonderful
recipe i'm going to send it to my uncle
in germany
and the uncle in germany says you know
my family has emigrated to the united
states i'm going to send this recipe to
the united states and they say i'm going
to disseminate it to all my relatives
and eventually to friends and neighbors
and eventually there are thousands of
copies
of the original recipe
then some faker comes along and says i'm
going to change this recipe
i'm going to change this ingredient for
that ingredient for that ingredient and
he sends that out
and then somebody says but you know what
this is a fake copy
now how do we know which one is the real
one because this one will say no this is
the real one exactly all right
so now you compare
this new one
with this great cloud of witnesses which
says the opposite
then you can conclude that this one must
be a fake
but in the case of bible translations
they say
well you know the oldest one that we can
find is this one
but
there's only one copy now we found two
oh we found a little supporting
miniscule and magiskal over here and
there and we have about five or six that
say this is the real one but there are
10 000 that say it's not the real one
but because it's older this one is more
reliable yes that's the argument that is
the argument but it is a very poor
argument because it's easy to say that
because of all the copying and
everything that kept on being current
yes
and being older means it weren't
distributed it wasn't
and being an older one it means it
wasn't used and distributed so correct
so martin
if this recipe
has been disseminated to the whole world
and everybody has the recipe and now
there's suddenly a new recipe
that comes out then some people will say
but you know this old recipe is tried
and proved
and everybody has the same recipe this
is a new recipe
then you know this will cause a debate
modern bible versions differ from the
received text in so many places that it
is impossible to produce a conclusive
doctrine
from a study of these perversions
here follows a short summary of the many
changes deletions and additions which
can be found in these versions now
modern i wrote that down
because when i started studying this
issue
it became a very
overwhelming
study
now let me make it quite plain
that when i started
studying the bible
i used the niv as my first bible
and eventually
that bible became virtually unusable
because it started falling apart
especially in the chapters that i was
studying very frequently
and i actually brought brought my first
niv
and here it is
this is my first niv bible leather bound
nice little bible
and
it is marked and if i go to the final
chapters where it becomes very important
you can see martin it's frayed
and it's fallen apart
and if i shake it half of it would
probably fall out
as you can see it seems like you've been
dabbling a lot in revelations yes martin
i don't know why the book had such a
fascination for me isn't it a closed
book well so some people say and you can
see that it's fallen apart
so it became virtually unusable
and i then got another niv the same as
this one
and it didn't
survive the onslaught either
and then eventually i
graduated from the niv to the new king
james version
and then the more i studied eventually i
graduated to the king james version now
i had a number of them
and i also used
the study bible versions
and some with the notes of spirit of
prophecy this is now my
one which has no notes in it so that
i can just read what the bible says and
not have to you know spend time on what
other people say just just to mull what
god say i'd like to know what god said
so this is the bible that i use at the
moment
and i have basically graduated from the
one to the other
to
this bible over here in the english
language
of course i also
read the bible in
german and in afrikaans and maybe that's
important because i'd like to come in
here and just clarify some things
there are people that are very
passionate about the king james only
yes and i understand because personally
and i'm sure you will agree like you
said you're now on the king james
version that's the best english version
of the bible and the true word that you
can find
there are however
some words not doctrines
words that are not
totally correctly
translated you must understand that
it doesn't depend on
the translation that you are reading it
depends on the manuscripts that it is
translated from
now some of those words are difficult
words definitely and some of the the
words in the ancient documents are such
that they're not in common usage anymore
because language has changed
so the translators of even the king
james version had some problems with
some of the particular words especially
when it came to the animals what animal
were they referring to in leviticus and
so there are a number of variations
possible and the king james for example
didn't always get it absolutely right
they refer for example to
unicorns
now we know there is no such thing as a
unicorn
so
the modern translations might have a
better word than say wild ox
now does that make the modern
translation a better translation if it
totally distorts
the doctrine that's what i
want to make clear
i did when i speak and say that
i mentioned in a previous one that the
king james is not infallible
what i meant was there are certain words
that's translated like that that's not
correct in in terms but it's still
there's no doctrinal
problems in the king james it's the word
of god
and the reason why i'm saying it's
difficult to only
say that the king james is the only one
because i speak afrikaans now i've got
an afrikaans bible actually two the one
is a
1933-15 and 53 translation that was done
on the received text it's called the
author
which means old translation translation
this is exactly the same as the king
james maybe with a word or year that's
also not totally and absolutely correct
and could be translated better yes and
this but doctrinally it is sound it's
sound then you've got the 1983 one
that's called the new translation the
nivea farther and then it gets
totally a me these verses this is like
the same as the niv almost yes
and that's because that bible is no
longer based on the received text but is
based on the westcott and hort text
which is based on the syntheticus and
the vaticanus as the prime
references and then of course based on
how nestle hollande put it together and
the united bible society
and those bibles that are based on those
manuscripts have the support of roman
catholicism
whereas those that are based on the
receive text do not have that support
you see and that also makes a difference
you
all the new translations that are
translated from those manuscripts
to my mind
automatically have to be approved by
rome
because that's the manuscripts that were
approved have you got another bible
there
no i've got there's another one that
just came out
the 2020 direct translation but from
which manuscript was it translated
martin it's the same as this one if you
go and see the verses that are left out
the changes that were made in the 1983
new translation you've got exactly the
same problem in the neutrons that 2020
so the wording might be more modern and
the grammar might be slightly different
but it's still based on those
manuscripts that were found in waste
paper baskets with thousands of changes
in you see and the other thing is
we don't understand well i can't read
hebrew or greek
but at least i know that the the texts
receptors or the received texts are the
correct manuscripts so when i get to the
bible in the english or in the afrikaans
that's translated
from them in the old
but the critics will tell you martin
that those manuscripts that you are
referring to
are not the most ancient the most
ancient ones are the seneticus and the
vaticanus and they also tell you that
the received text is a conflator text
yes now why do they say it's a conflated
text
because theirs has been reduced so if we
wanted to counter that we would have to
say
that theirs
is a deflated text that's it it's the
same argument
so what happens there martin is is as
simple as this
the receive text has many repetitions
now any good teacher
and the greatest teacher that ever lived
was jesus christ right yeah and he's the
word
any good teacher will know that if he
wants to bring a point across
he has to repeat it
in different forms
so repetition is the way in which we
learn i know i was a
lecturer at university
and when i lectured on a particular
subject and i explained and i see the
light bulbs going on
in the minds of the students
but i see this shadowy glazed look in
some others then i know some got it but
some didn't
right
any lecturer worth his salt should
study his students
to see whether his point is coming
across there's nothing worse
than a lecturer who stands there in the
front and dryly recites his lines
irrespective of whether the audience
understands or not it's dreary you might
as well stay at home and read a book and
i can
relate why you then why we are actually
then doing this once again yes because
we've realized again some people
either don't understand or misinterpret
what we say yes
so the proof of the pudding is always in
the eating so when you see that the
students don't understand
you repeat it in another way
and then when you see that some of them
understand but some still don't
understand you repeat it still in
another way and sometimes
if you do not get the point across
you have to change the story
into a parable
and make a story that they can relate to
and then they will understand
so this is how teaching works if you
take the bible as a whole if you take
the old testament
the old testament uses what we call
parallelism hebrew parallelism
in other words the bible says things in
one way and then repeats the same thing
in another way that's what a good
teacher does
and then the bible is a legal document
as we discussed and a legal document has
to have more than one witness
and so
you find a lot of repetition
so now these very intellectual people
say we don't need this repetition we'll
take it out
because
all of this needless repetition makes it
the conflated text
while removing all of that repetition
makes it a deflated text
and the question is which one is now
right
now i find it interesting that when you
take out some of these repetitions you
also destroy chiastic structures yes
now built into
the writing there are these chiastic
structures which bring out central
points
that are important
and if you miss that point
then you've you've lost the heart of
what is being said
and if you if you go through the book of
revelation or any one of them like you
said if you don't study revelations
through the chiasm you'll be studying it
in reverse
and you'll get totally confused no
wonder they say these things are closed
books
so we've seen some of the changes
already
and
that's why i want to come back to
like we don't unders we can't read
hebrew or
greek
before you continue
the spirit of prophecy clearly says that
we do not need it it might be necessary
for some
but
it will create more confusion in some
that is necessary and tyndall said that
the plowman can understand more than
many of these great learned men
by simply taking the word as it stands
and that's true and that's why i want to
just say that
if we want to say that the king james
bible is the only
true word of god then what about people
that can't read english then it's just
as good as them that me not being able
to read greek or what is that right
so that's why in the afrikaans in the
german in the romanian in every
language
god has like the spirit of prophecy said
preserved his word
his true word now have you heard me
preach in afrikaans yes have you heard
me preach in german yes all right and
the one which bible will i use then will
i use the king james no no i'll use the
old afrikaans version or i'll use the
king james version today in the old days
i might have used the niv
and i might have used the new king james
version but it's like a child that gets
a tricycle
and he's overwhelmed with excitement
with his tricycle
but once he's outgrown his tricycle and
moves to a bicycle he won't be easily
tempted to go back to his tricycle
and you know how it became easier for me
is the more you read the spirit of
prophecy
because the doctrinal issues that she
always talks about will coincide with
the true word of god so then when you
read any translation and it doesn't go
and coincide with that then you know
there's something wrong here
why i
say i i find it difficult to use the new
translations today
because you see that i certainly did
read the other versions i mean can i
just
follow in here sometimes they sentiment
because your grandmother and your
grandfather gave you
that translation a new a new translation
but
keep it don't throw it away
but if you want to read the real word
use it as a reference reference
now you know if you take the very latest
one that just came out in the afrikaans
the 2020 is it
direct translation the 2020 direct
translation doesn't it say there in that
bible that the heavenly beings had
relations sexual relations
with humanity and this is where you know
these infidels came from giants
right now that is absolute nonsense but
it stands in it
just because the language might be
modern and exciting
when the content and the doctrine is a
load of nonsense
then can you consider it the word of god
unfortunately you have to say no
it cannot be considered as a word of ah
so when it comes to truth
thy word is truth
it's not a question of did i get the
translation of this particular animal
correct or not
when it comes to the what it says
what it says about the doctrine as to
what i should believe
if the one says one thing and the other
one says another
then there must be two sources
and one of them can be correct and the
other one must be incorrect right that
is the point so let's look at a couple
of these examples
martin i put together a document now let
me make it quite plain
i put this document together for myself
as i was studying these things and as i
was
discovering them in the bible
they started to have an impact on me
you know where the king james talks
about jesus christ as the son
the new king james will refer to him as
the servant
the servant of god not the son of god
and eventually if you read that for the
20th 30th time it starts irritating you
and eventually it starts irritating you
so much that you put the book aside and
you get the real thing all right now you
have to get used to the thine vowel and
we've had a whole lecture on that and
i'll just
put it bluntly
it's more difficult for somebody that's
first language is not english
but
the holy spirit helps you
when you start studying that i couldn't
read the king james in the in the
beginning and understand it but it took
time and work with the holy spirit and
reading the spirit of prophecy and then
it gets easier and the interesting thing
about the king james is it's
self-explanatory
because you have hebrew parallelism so
it says things in one way and you don't
understand it but the very next sentence
clarifies it if you remove
those repetitions well then you're in
big trouble
so
even when it comes to language we'll
talk about that at the later stage but
let's just look at some of the changes
so this document
i put together for
myself it's just a summary and it's
written cryptically it's not for
publication
it's not for general use
but
we can put it in as an appendage so
people can look at it there might be
spelling mistakes in it
and it was just for myself but i'll make
it available and people can look at it
so if i can clarify this is like when
you're studying and you scribble down
notes on a piece of paper you've just
put it on a document on the computer
eventually i put it together all right
so martin
just so that people can see
the enormity
of what has actually happened how many
changes there are how many differences
there are between a translation based a
direct translation on the received text
and a dynamic equivalent drug
translation on the alexandrian
manuscripts just so that people can see
let's have a look at some of the points
in this document
all right martin as i said this is just
a summary it's written cryptically
but it'll give you a general view as to
what the situation is
so i titled it bible and bible
translation summary of changes
and there's a little introduction here
quite a short little introduction
and it talks about the septuagint which
we've talked about many times the
septuagint was made for the alexandrian
library in about 285 bc
the vulgate which is the latin
translation
uh was done in 383 to 405 a.d and the
old testament was
written between 1
500 and 400 bc
so we can see that they are separate
from what we find over here in the
alexandrian library and the vulgate
the old testament canon was complete in
the time of ezra and then the new
testament it tells you what the dates
were more or less when these particular
documents in the new testament was
written what's interesting martin
the old testament apocrypha
those are additional books that
catholicism loves to place in their
bibles
these were always written after the
canon was already complete
the same with the new testament the new
testament was complete and the
apocryphal new testament writings also
appeared
much later
so the apocrypha
who were declared canonical
by the catholic church at the council of
trent and they said whoever shall not
receive as sacred and canonical
all these books and every part of them
as they are commonly read in the
catholic church and are constrained in
the old vulgate latin edition
or shall knowingly and deliberately
despise the aforesaid traditions let him
be accursed
that's the council of trent
fourth session
now the protestants never included
the apocrypha originally when they
started off
they were considering them
and you'll still find old new king james
version bibles that have the apocrypha
in them but they were totally removed
once the protestant world realized what
they were all about and it's of course
obvious why they shouldn't be included
because if you take for example tobias
which is a apocryphal book
it teaches bewitching art
which is rebuked in mark in acts
it teaches works
in tobias 12 8-9 which is rebuked by
peter
it preaches prayers for the dead for
example in the book ii maccabees
which is rebuked in
the bible so it contradicts the bible
and if something contradicts
it cannot have the same source correct
it's as simple as that and we don't have
to go through them all
then there's a little study in here as
to how god communicated his word
that
it was the voice of god in some cases
angels prophets dreams
etc
how to read the bible
the attributes of the bible
and the study by repetition
so this is what the bible tells us
basically so it's just a short little
summary
let's just look at the new king james
for example which is you know touted as
one that should be
used
because it replaces the archaic language
so-called of the king james
well the new king james omits the word
lord 66 times god 51 times heaven 50
times the word repent 44 times
the word blood which is very important
23 times
the term new testament
like the
covenant of the new testament in the
blood for example
it totally the word damnation is totally
removed it ignores the textus receptors
200 times
it replaces the hebrew bin chai yim used
by the king james version with the ben
asher old testament
and that creates a number of problems
a number of
issues that are important are then
mentioned in this little section but
just to show the gravity of the
situation
if you look at other translations versus
affected
in the new american standard version
version 909 verses that's a lot
in the revised version 788 verses are
affected in the new world translation
767 in the niv 695
in the good news 614 verses in the
amplified
421 verses in the old jehovah's witness
bible 120 verses now it's interesting
when the old jehovah's witness bible
came out with 120 verses affected there
was a huge outcry
now look at the new
standard version new american standard
version with 909 verses affected and
nobody says a word
does that make any sense martin
the niv removes the word lord 39 times
jesus 87 times christ 52 times
and
617 words of jesus
are removed so if jesus is the word and
you live by every
not by bread alone but by every word
that proceedeth for the mouth of god
it's quite serious if you take 617 words
away from jesus that's a serious issue
yes
then i talk a little bit about the
westcott and north text and what it's
based on the vaticanus and the syneticus
these
manuscripts that were found in the
deserts and in the vatican library
when the spirit of prophecy tells us
that they were not the custodians of
god's word
so modern there were attempts to corrupt
god's word even in the times of the
apostles we read it in second
corinthians 2 17 for example
constantine ordered an economical bible
and eusebius our oregon follower
directed the work 50 copies were made
and the vaticanus and syneticus are
probably surviving copies of that
and eusebius
we know was an ecumenical bishop
the vaticanus manuscript was discovered
in 1481 in the vatican library and the
syneticus was discovered in 1844
and on these two manuscripts
largely depends what is written in the
new translations and just for interest
sake
large portions of the book of genesis
and revelation are missing
so they rely on a couple of minuscules
and magiscals that they found that still
have the book of revelation in it but
they add only those alexandrian ones and
not the great cloud of witnesses that
you had as an alternative so this is all
very interesting
let us just look at a few changes to sow
the gravity of the situation
if you look at bible verses removed
matthew 12 47 17 21 18 11
mark has versus missing luke john acts
romans
james let's just take verses taken away
in the new testament alone
and not only taken away
but sometimes left in the text but taken
away in the footnotes
in other words the footnote will say
this was probably not in the original
right so they cast doubt
upon the word of god who is the great
one who likes to cast doubt did god
really say this exactly satan satan does
that right
so let's have a look
if you take the niv the nisv the new
king james the revised standard version
the nrsv the ncv the liv etc
then you will see
taken away in the footnotes and taken
away in the text you can see matthew a
whole lot of verses mark luke and the t
stands for taken away in the text the if
taken away in the footnotes it's a
comprehensive list let me just scroll
through it
luke
luke john
acts
now
not only do they take away whole verses
they take out portions of verses
so for example if you look at the book
of matthew
then you have all of these verses and
these are the portions that i've written
on the right here
that have been omitted now when you make
a study of them
you will see that some of these portions
are incredibly important
and in fact
in some cases there are whole chapters
written in the spirit of prophecy on
verses that are missing or portions of
verses that are missing so they must be
based on the receive text right that's
the thing
so just look at them
matthew for example and this is not
a complete list this is just
what i noted down as i went through
these issues
and
you know important things like many be
called but few are chosen
and look at them mark these are portions
of verses that have been omitted
and
they're quite extensive
so you can see the problem is large it's
not a small problem see it's that's a
thing see looking at it like this
it gives you some perspective
so let's look at the book of romans for
example let's take eleven verse six but
if it be of works then it needs no more
grace otherwise works is no more work
i mean important portions corinthians
galatians ephesians
philippians colossians i mean this is
just what i wrote down
so
300 new testament bible verses changed
in the seven most popular
new translations and here they are you
can look at them
and some of the things that are changed
and in which ones they are changed now
it's interesting that all of the modern
versions
don't change the same thing
so you have a smorgasbord
some you have this change some you have
that changed some you have this omitted
some you don't so you said but you know
it still stands here
but very often
the second witness is removed therefore
not making it the legal document anymore
so if you look at the changes you can
see in matthew
i mean it's an extensive list
go down
verses removed versus changed
they are not the same manuscripts
anymore
not the same book you're not reading the
same book can you then still call it
the complete word of god well if man
lives by not by bread alone but every
word that proceeds out of the mouth of
god then we have a serious problem here
with all these words gone right
now this is one thing to remove verses
and to
replace certain sections but when you
change the meaning
then it becomes problematic is this a
minor change or is this massive
then here's a list of verses
that removed the name of god or the name
of jesus
if you take matthew alone just look at
all the jesuses that have been removed
in the various verses so why would you
want to do that who's trying to get rid
of jesus
obviously
the enemy
must be
look at this in mark
son son of god jesus forth with jesus
jesus jesus i mean it's incredible
john look at this
acts
romans
corinthians
galatians ephesians
that's substantial isn't it
this is amazing
now this is very important list of
verses that alter the meaning
now once you start dabbling with the
meaning you have a serious problem
all right
so for example
uh if you are angry with your brother
then you are in danger of hell fire
now the king james says
if you're angry without a cause
otherwise nobody will go to heaven it's
a very important change it alters the
entire meaning of this of the subject
now i'm not going to go into details
here
but
you know
jesus is made a liar for example i'm not
going up to this feast
as opposed to i'm not yet going up to
the feast there's a big difference big
difference all right mark
etc now they'll tell you martin
that these differences
don't really matter because you're not a
textual scholar
now martin
do you have to be a textual scholar to
see that two verses say the opposite
thing
and that's exactly where the problem is
you have to have logic as well when you
study the bible
if it's not logical then what's the
point right
you want there are certain things that
you cannot understand no because that
pertains to god that's where you get
your faith
correct brought in you cannot understand
where god comes from
all that you can understand from his
name is that he is yes now how do i know
that he is well i am therefore he is
that's it right so i can understand from
the things that are made
that there must be someone who made them
there are things which are
incomprehensible for the human mind
but when it comes to the plain logic
of what is presented
you cannot have cross purposes even with
the part that you have to have faith
once you've established your faith then
the rest becomes logical to put into
that if god is the supreme creator then
if he said it create
you so you have faith in this now in
genesis 1 he created all things then
it's easy it's logic that he created it
now if you look at all of these changes
let me just go back
and show changes that actually
alter the meaning
this is very substantial in matthew
in mark
in luke
in john
in acts
in romans
in corinthians
in galatians in ephesians
in timothy
in hebrews in james in peter
in the book of revelation is this an
important issue martin
would you like to have so many changes
and have to choose between two meanings
in that many verses in the book of
revelation alone
and it applies to the old testament
because it also depends on exactly what
you are relying to when it comes to the
old testament
so this is a very very serious issue
the document is by no means complete
now many books that you can read on the
subject make up your own mind
would be my suggestion let's look at a
few verses
so here we have a few specific examples
of changes in modern bible translations
if you go to acts 2 30
therefore being a prophet and knowing
that god had sworn with an oath to him
that of the fruit of his loins according
to the flesh
he would raise up christ to sit on his
throne that's the king james
it's read it in the niv you can
immediately see that it's a shorter
version it's a deflated text not and
this one is not a conflated text
but he was a prophet and knew that god
had promised him on oath that he would
place one of his descendants on his
throne
so this pitiful change is based on the
witness of syneticus vaticanus and four
other manuscripts
martin one of his descendants on his
throne couldn't that be anyone
huh
doesn't that refer to solomon yeah
but according to the flesh he would
raise up christ to sit on the throne
isn't that important
it's a pitiful change how anybody would
want to ride on a tricycle when you have
discovered the bicycle makes no sense on
to me whatsoever if you're going to go
to war by the way is the bible a weapon
of war yeah it's a sword it's a sword
the sword of the spirit so in modern
terms
the king james here would be an
intercontinental ballistic missile as
opposed to a water pistol over here
because we are talking about one of the
descendants
i get hot under the collar i should calm
down
that's
they totally denigrate
god
here's another example 1 timothy 3 16
and without controversy great is the
mystery of godliness god was manifest in
the flesh
justified in the spirit scene of angels
preached unto the gentiles believed on
in the world received up into glory
doesn't that verse have power
n.i.v beyond all question the mystery of
godliness is great he appeared in a body
who's he martin were you did you appear
in a body or are you a ghost
appeared in the body okay was vindicated
by the spirit was seen by angels
was preached among the nations was
believed on in the world and was taken
up in glory
so the niv rendition he appeared in a
body leaves plenty of room for gnostic
roman catholic sentiments
in 1 john 4 3 the niv also leaves out
the term in the flesh
as they do in acts 2 30 again following
the lead of nestle hollande
this is a trend
martin here's another important verse
which addresses righteousness by faith
versus righteousness by works
revelation 19 verse 8
and to her was granted that she should
be arrayed in fine linen clean and white
for the fine linen is the righteousness
of the saints
king james version
the new king james and to her it was
granted to be a raid in fine linen clean
and bright for the fine linen is the
righteous acts of the saints
martin that's roman catholic doctrine
works
the niv
says fine linen bright and clean was
given her to wear fine linen stands for
the righteous acts of god's holy people
that's like going from
a bicycle
to a tricycle
to a tricycle with a flat wheel
it's just unbelievable the whole
doctrine has changed because
righteousness the bible is clear all our
righteousness is filthy right so who is
the righteousness of the saints
christ christ
so this is a total doctrinal change and
it is a pitiful doctrinal change and
it's based on the council of trent
if we go to genesis chapter 2 verse 8
the king james says and abram said my
son
god will provide himself a lamb
for a burnt offering so they went both
of them together
the new king james changes this to my
son god will provide for himself
the lamb for a burnt offering so the two
went
together
martin
this is a totally different doctrine now
god needs a lamb to be sacrificed for
him
acts 3 13 in the king james
says the law the god of abraham and of
isaac and of jacob the god of our
fathers has glorified his son jesus
christ
whom ye delivered up and denied him in
the presence of pilate when he was
determined to let him go
the new king james changes this to the
god of abram isaac and jacob the god of
our fathers glorified his servant jesus
and the new king james does this over
and over and over glorified his son
jesus this is my beloved
servant
did he say that no no this is my beloved
son
whom you delivered up and denied in the
presence of pilate
these are the changes
that make it unpalatable
for me
to read these versions i agree although
i studied them yeah
and i did the same with the afrikaans
bible when i saw these things i went and
i made a whole list in the back of my
bible where i compared the afrikaans
versions
the new and the old
and you find the same problem you find
the same problem
well let's take a look at the hebrews 2
verse 16. for verily he took not on him
the nature of angels but he took on him
the seed of abraham that's so sublime
the new king james for indeed he does
not give aid to angels but he does give
aid to the seed of abraham
or the niv it is certainly abraham's
children that he helps he doesn't help
angels martin this is such a
travesty you see
this
put logic to that it's pathetic
i'm sorry but it's pathetic
did god
michael jesus christ come to the aid of
gabriel when he was contending with the
devil yes
in terms of the information that should
be going to daniel
so it doesn't even make sense to put
something like this in there
what about forgiveness martin
and when you stand praying forgive
if you have ought against any that your
father also which is in heaven may
forgive you your trespasses
but if you do not forgive neither will
your father which is in heaven forgive
your trespasses
now the niv
says and when you stand praying if you
hold anything against anyone forgive
them so that your father in heaven may
forgive you your sins and they leave out
verse 26 it's a conflated text martin
because in another place it actually
does say that in the niv which proves
that it is a conflated text the king
jones version
what about repetition a good teacher
uses repetition exactly and if you take
out the repetition in the eponatis in
revelation chapter 1
then you have destroyed the whole
chiastic structure but they're so clever
they take out i'm the alpha and omega
where it is repeated because obviously
it's a conflated text
i wonder how these people think
sometimes
so those are just a few examples of the
changes
that occur
now the list that i showed of those that
changed the meaning is considerable
we've taken
one or two or three out of that and said
well does it say the same thing or does
it not say the same thing
now we'll be dealing with this in a
little bit more detail yes because we
cannot put all of this because it's a
lot of information again yes cannot put
this all into one lecture no so
what is very important to me
and i'm sure to you as well
is how do the modern versions
affect the doctrine
that we as a denomination hold dear yes
and if that doctrine is not sustained by
the modern versions
then i have to come to the conclusion
that either
we have the wrong doctrines or we have
the wrong manuscripts yes when they
don't support the doctrine right correct
so
let us do another one
where we will look at the effect on the
doctrines that we hold dear
and i hope that this study will not be
seen as a major attack on anyone
because it is a sensitive issue and you
have a bible and you've become
accustomed to it
and you read it and you know i've
internalized this niv to such a great
extent because i read a number of them
before i graduated to the
new king james and then graduated to the
king james
that
it becomes problematic because some of
those verses are stuck in my head yes
and then sometimes you recall those
verses and it's actually not even the
right one correct and then when i look
for a verse i can't find the wording
because i'm actually thinking this one
and not that one so it makes life very
complicated but maybe we can just state
it here we'll probably state it in the
next one again
that
once again what we've explained here we
cannot say the king james only but we
can say that the most reliable one in
the english language is the king james
yes if you want to you can of course
read the geneva bible but you will have
to struggle with chaucer's english which
is considerably more complex
and as we said before if you are
struggling with the thine thou
ye
then just remember that that is the most
accurate form for example
i tell you he says to nicodemus
ye must be born again
so he's not addressing nicodemus because
then he would have said thee
ye is plural it applies to everyone so
once those nuances become important to
you they open up another dimension in
the bible let us step up to a higher
plate that's it let us not be degraded
down
to
this mundane
level god wants to elevate his people
not bring them down
to a common denominator
let's pray
heavenly father
thank you that we may study the word
and thank you that we may have
confidence
that your word is available to us
help us to study it because thy word is
truth
and because it teaches us that thy son
jesus christ is the truth the way and
the life in jesus name amen
[Music]
you